anyway so that's uh the single one uh
the single mommy let's take it over to
the next one you guys are busy in the
chat over there I'm gonna catch up on
that and see what's going on in there in
a sec let me just do the next article
here
all right so the third and final one
is the d-bag tax the D-Back tax and let
me grab the link to join because when
I'm done this
we're gonna take some call-ins uh Tua
let me drop this here if you're watching
this twitch Twitter twatch Facebook
anywhere else come on over to YouTube
the unplugged Alpha make sure you
subscribe because that's the only place
that I dropped the join link going in
and ask a question
so I'll just pin it to the top it's a
streamer link make sure you have a good
connection por favor
play
tootsuite all right
um
there we go
close this
the d-bag tax New York Post this is
always a smutty [ __ ] article for the
most part when it comes to this one so
we've got uh Emily Lefroy here I don't
know is this about Emily or is this
somebody that she's writing about
doesn't it just has archive it doesn't
have Social Links anyway New York women
are charging men up to three thousand
dollars for failed relationships and bad
dates the d-bag tax somebody sent this
to me a few days ago
uh Martha Duke sends venmo requests for
amounts ranging from one thousand five
hundred dollars to three thousand
dollars to dates who behave poorly I'm
assuming this is her here with the space
goggles
that is so bizarre
okay so it says here Sarah was fed up a
New York social City New York City
social worker who declined to give her
last name so this is not Martha Duke
over here pictured uh had had countless
dates cancel on her at the last minute
so when a guy she met on an app recently
pulled out on a date an hour before
could you imagine doing this as a guy
like women flake on dates all the time
remember when um it was a couple years
ago Myron got like de-platformed from uh
was it tick tock for saying that he
would punish women for flaking on dates
and here we have the New York Post
celebrating women charging dudes up to
three thousand dollars for flaking
women charging guys that amount so when
she had not pulled out a date beforehand
she agreed to reschedule on her caveat
he would venmo her a 50 deposit
I'm just done with my time and energy
being Royce said Sarah told the posts
I'm sorry and almost every other
scenario when somebody books a time of
the day dedicated to you they have no
show policy or security deposit
I met
okay a man agreed to the terms and sent
her the money a loser why would you do
that they met up for a drink on Monday
night in Hell's Kitchen and he was and
he was fully engaged in the time paying
for their cocktails and offering to buy
them food to share Sarah's female
friends cheered her Brazen move while
male friends told her it was nuts
still she has no regrets I think it made
sense she said of the arrangement the
arrangement the arrangement women love
their Arrangements
I guess this is a screenshot of the text
right yeah if I'm going to ever give you
another shot I'm a need a secure I'm a
you can't you [ __ ] write it out man
for crying out loud Amma need a security
deposit or some something something
dude says I definitely owe you a round
or two now again sorry about that she
says security deposit needed LOL I don't
like wasting time haha what's your like
a simp
what's your venbo she provides it
there's a fifty dollars LOL thank you
you'll get that back if you do
everything right like a good little pet
like a good little beta pet that she's
never even gonna be interested in anyway
because you're a pleb
dating in that digital age can take a
toll both emotionally and financially
and some see the problem is guys is
there's too many Sims out there not
enough guys doing the work and out of
all of those categories of men they're
tolerating this [ __ ]
look women are more disagreeable than
they've ever been
they're
not as fit as they have been in the past
because you're told you look good at any
weight now all that kind of stuff
this this is a failure on both parts but
I blame I blame men for not being better
I mean like women don't hold guys to
standards men hold women to standards
that's really the way that it should be
but we've got chicks here holding nerds
to standards for 50 bucks
uh for me it's a way to just be like
you're a d-bag here's the monetary value
of my time you wasted Martha Duke 38
told the post is this Martha Duke up
here okay so this chick over here with
the space goggles is 38.
Jesus
so she charged 50 bucks is this the
thread here for 50 bucks that's what her
that's what her late time is worth 50
bucks for taking a shower and doing her
hair and put on clothes and makeup
she listed okay uh over the years the
different men okay so she's been doing
this for years now it says
sent around six memo requests fifteen
hundred three thousand she listed
infidelity secret marriages and hiding
having multiple sexual partners from her
as some of the reasons for the changes
putting a monetary value on kadish
conduct helps men to better understand
the error of their ways yeah yeah you
want to build a better beta is what
you're trying to do
Duke said that adding that she puts the
phrase the d-bag tax and all her venmo
requests could you imagine going out
with this one
hey Ma I want to introduce you to what's
her name Martha or Sarah
Martha Duke hey Ma I want to introduce
you to Martha
bring her home for Thanksgiving after
she charged you a 3 000 d-bag tax
New York is the narcissist Capital yeah
and you're the queen of them all
Duke who works as a personal assistant
said they're not going to understand
what you did really hurt my feelings
because they don't grasp feelings they
grasp money Duke says the venmo requests
have been cathartic and she's been
submitting them to Men Who offended her
in various ways one man had promised to
help her with rent
oh you're so strong and independent you
need dudes to help you with rent now
miss
narcissists the city's a narcissist
another abandoned her on a weekend
getaway in Atlantic City probably due to
your personality your looks I would
imagine because he expected more of her
a third dude ghosted her and resurfaced
a month later married to another woman
here's Martha's venmo
the douchebag tag she puts on here
twenty five hundred dollars
you'd have to be a real pleb to pay that
uh about half the time suitors pay up so
she's saying half the time guys pay up
I'm not surprised honestly the amount of
money that guys throw at
classless low value
trash like this is just off the chart
man only fans venmo requests
d-bag taxes
man the world's a mess it's a mess
Duke has been surprised at the success
of the request I'm not men are simps but
hypothesize that men would rather pay
than deal with the emotional
consequences because you're yeah if
you're dealing with narcissists you're
never going to get closure she said but
I get the mental image of them receiving
my vet yeah who's the narcissist here
asking dudes for twenty five hundred
dollars looking like this with your
space goggles on
come on
oh hang on we got another one Hazel says
she's 34 agreed that she sent a memo
request to a man she's been seeing for
several months after he stopped
communicating with her and sent her
another woman's nude photos
I just sent on memo requests 100 for the
Highlight I wrote okay so this one's a
hundred dollar bill instead of a 2500
bill
so Sarah she never won his second date
that paid the deposit no matter she came
out ahead of course yeah she got paid so
I kept the money I never heard from him
again she said so I kept the money he's
a loser were the comments on this is
there a comment threat they don't even
give you comments I guess they lock them
out oh here we go
if your dates keep canceling at the last
minute you are one picking the wrong
type of guys or two there's something
wrong with you they're finding on the
internet
hmm
yeah well the common denominator here is
if you've been doing this for three or
four years back to back and you've had
all these nerds send you all kind of
money there is definitely a problem with
the common denominator
if one woman believes as the movement
suggests men would all be in prison a
woman who recognizes that she's wrong is
such a rare commodity yeah
accountability is not normal MJ I
believe I heard a woman in 2019 say she
was wrong but I have to be but I could
have been dreaming women believe they're
never annoying entitled self-centered
and boring they are all of these things
and it only gets worse during their moon
cycle what the hell not to mention
menopause Moon cyclists calling it
where it's impossible on a summer day to
have AC blasting for an hour later turns
out the heat got free for you God free
me from her misery I'm Chase quite the
anyway I'm not going to read all the
comments there the the links to all of
these are in the description guys this
is these are the reasons why the ladies
are indicating that they are giving up
on dating
um
pretty simple right uh they think that
they can uh
attract better they're not getting
better so they're trying to hold guys uh
to standards being around their kids
um
flake standards attractive standards
four percent uh close rates on uh
dates from the first one didn't make any
sense she said 50 dates I calculated
over 700 based on her math for five
years
I don't know
you know
I've talked about this before there's
probably at least one or two videos in
my car where I was doing a clip on the
entrepreneurs and cars Channel
and there's always some dude that's like
asking some question about something
and there's an article or something that
comes up and it's like
you know these ladies have expectations
they don't hold themselves accountable
or to standards and you can't hold them
accountable to standards so they don't
they don't get the results they want
from the guys that they want you know
they want the Chads they want the good
looking dudes you know the funny the
captivating the interesting guys you
know the guys that make money the guys
with the nice cars the guys that are
tall
sort of thing it's like I've said this
before you know the North American
population and one of the prerequisites
that almost all women tend to have is
tall over six foot and it's like
something less than 15 percent of the
North American population is over six
foot uh many women in fact will ask for
six foot two uh Which is less than four
percent if you're not mistaken so you're
already excluding the vast majority of
the male population and like what are
they doing they're they're they're
complaining that they're not in their in
their kids frames they're complaining
that only four percent of the guys will
go out with them when they look average
at best they're complaining that
um
if they have to reschedule a date they
need a 2500 deposit or something like
that for what exactly it just doesn't
make any sense hey guys I really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out